hey guys welcome back to the corridor
cast I am ready to talk about AI world
governments I don't know about you but I
put an army helmet on for those of you
who are audio I brought my battle helmet
and should line it with tinfoil so they
can't get into your brain well yeah
that's I actually I have yeah it's
invisible tinfoil yeah so um I think we
should just start this off kind of
picking up where we left off last time
we were talking about machine learning
yeah we were having a nice conversation
about machine learning oh let me start
my watch okay we recognize conversation
about machine learning Nika was going
through the basics of kind of how it
works and what makes it different from
regular computational power and then
it's ability to sort of learn things on
its own and come to conclusions on its
own yeah it just eliminates the need for
you as a programmer to have to figure
out how do you get a computer to
recognize a face rather than having to
go in like plug in all the if thins in
addition and subtraction in algebra you
can just the computer will figure it out
you just say look the end of the day
this is what I want and this is what I'm
giving you
so try try try again a million times
over and over until you can figure it
out
skate Santa of AI wow what a reference
[Laughter]
well we were talking about AI and I just
blurted it out there how cool it could
be to have an AI government where you've
I've learned it out I don't want any
communistic computer overlords he said
that yes and then what did you said and
I basically reiterated that okay well I
don't want a communistic computer
overlord necessarily but what I do want
is I want a society that is able to
actually look at the data that it
generates and make like rational
decisions based off of it and I feel
like we currently don't really live in
that that world where we what we should
so let's let's go that's exactly what I
wanted to talk about and let's talk
about not only that but also honest
heaven on
conversation about the benefits and the
the burdens of that yeah and once again
I'm not it's not like I just I'm not
going into this with like evidence to
necessarily even support that statement
but I see issues that it could solve ran
that's why I feel like there's an
optimistic like a viewpoint to take on
it
issue one if you create an AI government
do you can do you complete the final
step and bring on a worldwide a
computerized organism online and now the
earth is one singular thinking entity
well it depends on sentient planet if
you will well I guess so I mean it
depends if the same government if
governments share the same like machine
learning algorithms to dictate I think
it might be a little important to kind
of clarify what kind of AI were kind of
talking about like the kind of AI that
can run a government is the kind of AI
that can run a world it's like if
there's not I mean there there's tons of
like perhaps smaller versions of AI but
they all have to be kind of assisted but
once you get to the level of like super
intelligence it's like you know an Elon
Musk is famous for saying it's like
opening a genie out of the bottle you
know three wishes if we get to the point
where there is like a super intelligence
it might be one of those situations
where we don't have a choice you know
it's like they it suddenly has control
over everything everything's digital it
can hack anything and everything all at
once and so now it just owns us that's a
possibility I'm not saying I want that
I'm not saying that's likely I'm just
saying that well it level of power doing
that we don't lose control for better or
for worse okay assuming that it's
fostered mhm and it's sort of introduced
so one of the bigger things that I mean
obviously there's a lot of things wrong
with our government especially right now
but one in general one of the downsides
to government is the bureaucratic speed
is incredibly slow you know they have to
like go back have meetings and
referendums and all this stuff and then
like eventually stuff gets passed and
eventually it goes into law and all this
stuff whereas like if you can have some
sort of informed intelligent
decision-making that can happen
that fast and be implemented just as
fast you could have a lot of like good
change
exactly really rapid and I think that
bureaucratic speed is you know I guess
it can act as a safeguard at times for
making like rash decisions and sometimes
that speed that it works at does work
for certain problems that it's trying to
tackle but at the same time there's many
other problems that we look at like the
whole corona virus in China there was
apparently someone was running a machine
learning algorithm that was tracking a
lot of like public transit and flight
data and it detected the when the virus
were actually started because he was
able to see from like how just people's
movement in and out of the city like
shifted and it was like basically
flagged it and things like that where
it's like that would be a really useful
tool and it's not and I guess it's I
guess it's the difference between having
it as like the tool that people can use
versus like something that people like
rely on to make the decision to to act
when you bring it up like that I think
the reality of this of an AI government
you know it's usually things are much
much less interesting and entertaining
than they are in fiction you know if you
look at a lot of businesses because
corporations are kind of just mini
governments in a way um with the
shareholders voting and they have their
elected representatives and all kind of
stuff and you know corporations serving
its own interests and that of its
shareholders so you know a lot of
businesses are basically algorithm run
at this point you can punch in the
numbers like okay we have this shipment
coming at this time and has this many
boxes and it's worth this much okay so I
can put my drivers this much fuel needs
to cost this much you know a lot of
things I just algorithm and it's just
people executing the algorithm now
whether the algorithm is an explicit
computerized algorithm or just the years
and years of experience and spreadsheets
that people have done to just know that
like I need about this many bricks to
build that house like you know I'm using
algorithm as a big blanket term here but
a lot of businesses are kind of run
where you know there's there's a flow of
formula to things and that's where you
know AI is already being used to
optimize that and to improve that and I
think in reality if you're looking at an
AI run government it's just that now
applied to the government and like you
said it eliminates a lot of the
inefficiencies that you get with you
know the government's effectively in
terms of
you know 20 30 years behind you know
modern economic you know business you
know institutions in terms of how its
organized and how things are processed
and that's just kind of how it has to
move because it's has to serve so many
interests that aren't profit bearing
interests yeah so that's this is an
interesting thing you brought up about
the efficiency and and getting rid of it
because there's there's two sides to
that and the human side of bureaucratic
inefficiency is sometimes considered a
net positive in the sense that well you
don't want the government reacting in
creating reactionary laws to every
little thing that comes along but that's
a emotional human side of of government
and so having a bureaucracy to protect
against that to sort of allow people to
go through absent flows of of decision
making before real concrete decisions
are made can have its benefits for
humans but when you're talking about the
functional inefficiency of government
which there certainly is an offensive
amount of having it solved that from
just everything from shipping to like
the way that it's you guys like district
layouts instead of gerrymandering yeah
yeah well yeah that would be that would
be one thing though there's arguments
for and against gerrymandering that's
true you ever hear the arguments for it
yeah well but everybody likes it both
parties like it that's the thing no
one's complaining about gerrymandering
that's that's but then also the way that
like the government distributes funds
and the way that it invests funds and
the way that it deals with the resources
of like on the day-to-day you know there
could be huge leaps and bounds of
efficiency improvements would write
about what if okay would it make
any of you uncomfortable if Siri ask you
questions no uh
so I mean part of me because part of it
wouldn't make me uncomfortable because I
feel like I'm just coming to terms with
the inevitable it's because it's like
you know what was that song you were
just listening to Ren if you were faced
with his paradoxical situation how would
you react and webserie did that for
millions of people eventually built up a
consciousness yeah a figure on the pulse
of the public if you will that guy's
I mean having like smart assistants like
Siri or Alexa has already like improved
my life be able to be able to like
automate tasks in my life to make them
simpler and quicker and more convenient
for myself the downside is that you have
an inherent loss of privacy you know I'm
Amazon Apple whoever you know they're
capturing that data they're using it
however it's their data now and in the
future I feel like it's we're in
inevitably heading towards the personal
assistance AI where everyone just has
like a fully like realized assistant to
help you out on day to day life that you
can have a conversation with kind of
like the movie her you know I don't know
how far away we are from something like
that but like can you imagine making
people pay a digital subscription to
have a pet an AI pet oh man and you have
to pay five dollars a month to keep it
alive okay
like let's say if every single person
can somehow or rather with something
like that every person can now be way
more productive and if that can trickle
through something like a government
agency uh who knows what kind of
benefits we could have from that well
let me pose another hypothetical then to
you because what you're kind of saying
about that digital assistance so you
basically that assistant is you know you
have the government assistant which is
basically running the government and
it's learning through the operation of
you know what's happening what it needs
to do but let's say there's a criminal
case right there's been a murder
no you guys know about it right it's
just it's murder that happened off
somewhere and you may feed the the
circumstances into the computer the
computer is going okay you're some what
ifs and then just on your daily life you
know when you have your conversation
with your ISS and goes hey there's a
what if for you
if somebody were you know we're to leave
at 6 p.m. and this thing would happen at
6:30 p.m. and they came back at 7 p.m.
and they said this would that seemed
normal
or that seemed weird and you go huh I'd
be a little weird it goes okay and
little do you know it's having that
conversation with it's like a million
other people engaging what's you know
what's right and what's wrong and you
basically secretly weighing the evidence
of say for example a criminal case and
then it comes to the conclusion by
having had a bunch of what if
conversations with a million people at
the same time yeah okay guilty would you
be okay with that how would you feel
about that is that the way to go cuz
arguably it's more we need to avoid that
isn't it arguably more accurate than a
are you making a case that if you can
kill someone and get away with it it's
legal driving a I courtroom right a I
judge sure it's just extra data for the
you know the defense or the offense not
the office no the computer itself would
be doing also like completely replacing
the quarter process okay so you give it
the evidence and the computers okay I
feel like everyone's gonna want to have
to maintain a human presence throughout
pretty much everything I see where
you're going with this and I do
there is certainly that that element
where the more you implement it the more
you kind of give people like a waiver
for critical thinking in the sense that
like you do have like you could
theoretically make an AI that does what
you're talking about today right now and
have it probably be pretty accurate but
then the question is is that when you
start relying on it it's kind of like
the court comes no one's done the
research they're like what does AI say
like it's like 70% sure it's like all
right the verdict but still though it's
like when you have so much assistance it
can you know make the process lazy I
suppose a dependable that's true but I
suppose even though Tesla's on a per
mile basis have a safer driving record
than human beings mhm
when is the AI is engage they still put
steering wheels on them because there's
no law to allow them to not baster
that's kind of point I'm making it
like they're from a technical standpoint
yet either but the alternative is just
12 people yeah you know it's like it's
like the alternative is like oh and even
better system necessarily like you know
right now 12 people is better than any
other system that's outsourced here's
the thing I don't think we can have
computers deprive human beings of life
liberty and property though that's
that's like a fundamental human right
that unity that another human needs to
judge you on not exactly not not a
computer but you can use that as
assistance like for research you know
you know the attorney comes in they've
done all their research what if like one
of their assets was they had this AI ask
a million people this thing and then
they could present that to the court as
part of their case I agree that that
could be useful much in the same way
that a lie detector can be useful it's
it's an amalgamation of data but again
it's you're you're undermining a
fundamental thing within Western justice
which is guilty until proven guilty yeah
and that is a fundamental right that
goes deeper than technology that goes
deeper then yes it goes to the core of
your of your humanity I I have a feeling
like people are gonna fight tooth and
nail for that right for the foreseeable
future like at the moment an AI is
making decisions for the outcome of a
person's career or life or whatever
that's when you start having trouble
right because well it just to think
about it like this like there's there's
certain like there's certain inalienable
rights that are that are laid out in the
Constitution but also that exists not
because of the Constitution or because
of anywhere that they're written down
but simply by being a living organism in
the universe
you possess a physical space you can
direct in command a physical space you
can have thoughts and foresee things and
then like convince other people or talk
to other people about these thoughts and
collectively work together like human
beings are of themselves a force of
nature I mean we created AI right our
nature yeah exactly so you
you can't lose those things regardless
of how much and this is me speaking
personally now I don't I don't think we
can we won't survive as a species in
accomplishing anything if we lose some
of these things like that are so
fundamental to just being a being a
living organism like it has to do with
your happiness it has to do with your
yeah value and and if you if you let an
AI sort of like get in the way of that
because most of the time it's right you
lose there's a disconnect now and you
start to lose this the essence of our
humanity starts to become further and
further hold apart I think and it's
important to remember that that's like
is efficient and as purposeful as it
could be like we can't let it get in
between those things here's a concern of
mine so in theory one of the great
things about an AI is that its objective
right it's gonna make objective
decisions without any sort of external
forces applied upon it the problem with
that is that that is definitely not the
case any AI is a direct extension of
whoever created that AI right and so you
know democracy for example is something
that represents the idea of the people
and a lot of you know in today's
politics that's not the case you know
you have special interests involved
corruption etc and so you know no one
feels like their politicians represent
them in that perhaps that's been the
case for a long time it just feels extra
the case these days so my gut reactions
and then it'll actually represent
everyone it will be able to have that
conversation with every person in
America or whatever country and you know
make the correct choice but again that
AI was programmed by someone
it was probably programmed by Facebook
it was probably programmed by Google
right whatever whoever created the super
intelligent AI is gonna have its own
coded special interest and so it's that
that's the concern of mine oh absolutely
yeah and you can't I
so here's the thing like the inherent
weird thing that we need to ask here but
it is which needs to be asked in your
analysis thereof like well if you had an
AI that was super intelligent that was
perfectly unbiased and it was able to
talk to everyone in America and
perfectly aligned representation and
resources and all these other things
that assumes that everybody from every
leader of every section of society to
every drug addict and drunkard and thief
has the exact same resource and access
to those rights hmm no matter what and
is that so there's two questions is that
a society that we should want to live in
and what does that mean for earning
things in life do you lose something
from that do you know I'm confused what
it would feel like spoiling that again
yeah yeah so like you think if you think
in the analysis it's like all humans are
the same so let's take all their
information and we'll will combine all
their information and we'll tally it up
and we'll we'll perfectly according to
our unbiased distribution of resources
we will perfectly distribute justice and
and and and resources and representation
equally amongst every single human being
you don't have to go I'm still confused
like like that's is that isn't would
that be the point is to that yeah that
would be the point
that exactly I'm saying is is that that
that that recognizes all the problems
and different types of people and
understands how to try and make that
better yeah well yes obviously you'd
want us to do that but that would
inherent in order what do you mean by
making it better right because would
more I mean once we could boil it down
to specific like questions or specific
tasks so to speak so like the whole like
gerrymandering thing yeah all right so
basically you
want districts to i guess what what is
the goal of creating a voting district
well it's technically to have a an even
distribution of different types of
people in a certain area right well
these gerrymandering circumvents that
that allows for a more voting
demographic so that more people from
certain parties get elected exactly and
it skews votes in a artificial way
because of that so taking that as an
example let's say you use an AI to
basically look at district lines and go
alright the goal is to more evenly
represent types of people in here so
it's not over representing people per
square mile or whatever you know like
whatever density you're looking for yeah
and so let's say it comes with an
outcome and you are you saying that
outcome is unfair well yeah but I'm
saying it could be because think about
it this way if you take take the
gerrymandering example you have a voting
district that's all over the place
because this is the demographic where
you know most of the we'll just take us
for example most of the white males of
the age of mid-30s live right so it's
like you want these people okay and this
party wants these people to vote so they
select them and they're like great now
this group of people has this
representation right but if you took it
and you broke it down into actual like
geographical squares for example or you
broke it down to per capita so there's
exactly one hundred thousand people in
each district and each voting district
that could necessarily would just D it
would just create in a situation in
which everything is just done by
majority or like equal distribution no
matter what and what I'm saying is that
isn't necessarily good for society just
equal distribution and and like perfect
everyone gets the same like that's not
necessarily a direction that we want to
go in
I think with AI well you know and people
would necessarily program an AI to act
that way right but I'm using that
pathetic oh I'm losing a possible a nerd
and going down this topic a little more
like you're they're certainly like a
version of this where if it's poorly
programmed you'll get like a district
that looks even crazier than something
that a human drew because it's trying so
hard to create like an even distribution
and now suddenly the district looks like
bonkers because it's adding a couple
patches of extra people who really
shouldn't be in the mix generative
design concept it just like we designed
it a square and the a I designed this
fractal it looks like a fractal or
something like that and then it's
suddenly like well now it's an even
distribution but from a community
standpoint a lot of these people don't
share the same community so it's we're
basically nullifying votes say no I know
but that's like worst case scenario and
I feel like no one is looking for that
but when you take like what is a city or
like an actual like the the city limits
so to speak and you you work towards
trying to find a more balanced
distribution that doesn't it's I mean
basically you're comparing the shape
from a school area a surface area
standpoint to its distribution and
you're going alright I'm we're looking
for like like geographical like surface
area anomalies that are creating an
uneven distribution here and you're
trying to cut this off yeah I guess the
question is the underlying that though
is the the the AI or whoever programs it
or us as a culture need to determine
what unequal distribution means in that
sense and we need to determine it in a
lot more senses because this is
something that it eventually computer
machine learning will be able to somehow
influence and so under the example of
gerrymandering like that is that is the
underlying thing is like it sounds like
you're still a fan of having a little of
chaos and mischief in a system well you
do need a little bit mmm you do you
don't want like a little bit of entropy
yeah because it because otherwise
everything just becomes crystallized
and then everything is there's no
there's no mutation of any kind what
you're saying is an optimal life is in
fact to live a slightly suboptimal life
we need to not be fully optimized in
order to be well because you need it you
need an inherent amount of natural
mutation across all levels of society in
order to continue to reform into the
next best possible iteration of
ourselves yeah it's like you don't want
to watch a movie full of circus
performers perfectly flipping for an
hour and a half never messing up you
want a couple you want some of them and
have flaws you know you don't watch
NASCAR because they never crash no but
that's like storytelling yeah you want a
character to have its flaws so that way
there's a yeah a goal of something with
to overcome and a little bit of chaos
- here's create mistakes that people can
understand and grow from sure here's a
here's a so we'll make an AI that [ __ ]
[ __ ] up
[Laughter]
where's-where's life - good make they'll
just do like we'll just we're just gonna
like say that you should drive on the
left side of the road for one minute
it's a ways that if like you don't need
an AI to do that like some schmuck with
the control to do that can just be like
yeah so you say now well I mean you need
you need that if you are in you're too
perfect of a world that Jake hears no
not you I'm saying with Jake I feel like
we're tell me we're never gonna get to
perfection but I think the striving to
get there is worth something I don't
know I don't know where I was going with
that idea what I was trying to say is
what if we tried to way I write it can
do things very efficiently on a mass
scale yeah assuming we get to like a
much more powerful AI than machine
learning is right now yeah what if it
replaced the entire IRS
because you know you have all these
corporations paying zero dollars when
they owe billions of dollars in tax get
um Bernie um and like you know the IRS
is run by people and they're they
constantly every year have to review
every single person's taxes to make sure
that they're paying their fair do an AI
can analyze everything and instantly
know whether or not the person's
cheating and maybe like suggest the
correct amount immediately as in real
time as the person is making money and I
know there's a lot of things that how is
that different than what TurboTax is
right now well cuz that's that's still
being user submitted you know like I'm
talking about like an intelligence that
actually goes through owners like okay
this person needs to pay this much to
the government without that person it's
not even interesting minute because if I
your job like you get a w-2 and so
you're like the government I knows how
much you make and how much you have got
no I'm saying I'm saying like okay I
think everyone agrees that there needs
to be some sort of tax reform right like
you know you have billions of dollars
from the ultra-rich that are that should
be going into taxes that are not they're
going elsewhere or nowhere at all well
yes that is that is a place where AI
could potentially help everyone by
correcting that yeah but you I mean well
you have to be doing first and foremost
though is actually passing a law on
where the taxes are coming from because
you know we don't I don't get too deep
into Texas right now whether you know
for example the reason why corporations
don't pay taxes because the taxes are
paid on the individual level for the
people who profit from the corporation
so the the money still gets taxed yes I
think it doesn't get taxed by the
business it gets taxed when it's
actually ending up in somebody's pocket
that they didn't get to use personally
so you'd have to pass an actual law that
says like okay we're still gonna set
aside this much my now for taxes from
whatever operation are you know at
whatever process and like that's not
necessarily add your the thing though
maybe what could be AI driven per se is
worth it fluctuated every year what the
AOL is constantly analyzing okay I need
this much resources to do these many
tasks okay this is the tax right now Oh
next our war taxes going up boys I mean
that happens anyway well let's think
about this let's think about this for a
second because it's an inch
thing about tax and I think that that is
some there is some there is some utility
there that could certainly be you put
implemented but in all of these
conversations we keep that the weird
thing that we keep going to and I think
this is why this is such a topic that
like people are talking about right now
is because it cuts through the core of
like some of the other noise that's
going on into the world and it gets to
these really fundamental issues like in
the tax example you're you don't
fundamentally Oh anything to the
government that that's like the
fundamental flaw underlying philosophy
that we have constructed in the United
States and in other Western cultures you
as a human as a human being the
government doesn't have its power but
for you giving it to it the government
is our client exactly and so there
that's the idea that's the underlying
philosophy of the purpose of government
the purpose of government is to get in
the way of human beings from doing
certain things it is inherently intended
to be inefficient for the benefit of
others but in that inefficiency that's
what I'm saying so when you talk about
the tax thing it's like you're now not
just talking about like a way to make
the tax system more efficient it's also
it also cuts to the core of like well is
it self-evident that so-and-so or
such-and-such
should be paying more or should be
paying less in it and it cuts in and
that's what I'm saying is it's like and
we saw that in the like in the utility
side of the conversation we're seeing it
in the tax side of the conversation it's
well I think what you're really saying
is you know in in general you know the
government is set up American government
is set up in a way to approach decisions
in a way they're trying to be as fair to
all the parties involved as possible
sure you know versus other forms of
government we you know I say it's this
and that's because I say so
you know leadership yeah yeah and
obviously there's a whole ring
things in between you know on all ends
of the spectrum well let's take a step
back here we're so far we're kind of
like the ideas that we've been talking
about are ways to basically implement
versions of AI into our current working
government hmm but I feel like the basis
of what we came in here to talk about
was like what if our government was AI
like yeah it require it requires us to
literally rethink how government is run
well that's what I'm kind of getting to
so I you know generally generally
speaking the purpose of government at
least has been structured is to come to
decisions of how things should be run
where resources should go for the common
good in ways that businesses can't take
care of and I'm just speaking to the
American the current modern American
system and obviously there's a million
other nuances to this in August I'm just
throwing out here but at the end of the
day it's like well we had a hurricane
hit Florida and it's you know I'm gonna
cost this much money to fix it well
we're gonna skim a little bit off of
everybody you know ten cents per person
in the United States and boom floor is
fixed you know it's also not that simple
I guess need to happen and you know
right now there's a process with a
committee and it goes you know through
probably some form of Congress and the
emergency fund you know the executive
branch steps in and if something goes
wrong you just roll branch Kim sorts it
out you have all your different avenues
to deal with your issues with it and I
think they deal with it AI is that you
will eliminate a lot of that you
eliminate a lot of these steps because
the ideas of the computer is going to
make the best decision for everybody and
I think the reality is that if they ask
program well it does but for the people
that then get shafted in this equation
they no longer have an easy out they no
longer have an option there's never that
there's no longer that's shot in the
dark that maybe your lawyer just happens
to be really good and just maybe the
judge is having a good day and he looks
upon you in smiles and says you know
what I like chance Kay a second chance
kid right and also there's the
alternates that happened to and you have
great examples of all the shitty things
right all of them and corruption and the
awfulness that comes with that yeah so
do you want to give up your shot in the
dark you know for or maximize perhaps we
don't have perhaps it doesn't have to be
that that's what I'm proposing cuz like
we can go straight to like it but what
if the AI government right that's a
whole different sci fi conversation what
but what I think there's there's actual
real places
where you could you could implement
intelligence and have it make
improvements without getting in the way
of like these these fundamental human
rights Mike what do you think well-liked
by at the post office the maybe natural
disaster relief certainly the
distribution of energy and the and the
amount of money cost and sold and
purchased on that energy the guys
already playing a role in the
distribution hobby yeah probably I don't
know enough about that side of
investment but I mean those are just
like three off the top of my head that I
think could probably be significantly
improved perhaps tax at least in just
checking the balance sheet every year
well I think all of those areas are
gonna be influenced by AI to some degree
or another with an increasing amount
over time so it's like what time period
are we kind of expecting here not
necessarily like twenty years or four
years from here but like the
eventualities well what's a so you guys
know I get the phrase the the
convergence points the singularity yeah
it's our responsibility though to roll
it out so that we don't overstep or [ __ ]
something up well okay and and again
it's like we might there's a very real
possibility we won't have that option
because it's like when you get down to
it there's gonna be probably just like a
handful of corporations probably three
who all have similar levels of super
intelligence AI and it's gonna be a race
to see who can actually hit the
singularity and the whole point of the
singularity is once you hit it it's like
that's beyond
yeah is it's like you've created
essentially like a form of God not
actually you know I mean but like well
no the singularity is technically it's
where you can't predict what's going to
happen exactly so it's like you know but
in theory that it's it's so powerful
that nothing else compares I mean if you
have threes is this actually just before
we get too deep into this conversation
help help me understand okay is this
theoretically something that's
constantly in the distance because
aren't we at a point where AI are making
decisions that we don't know the outcome
of yet but they're they're they're very
simple decisions still very like
but what but isn't wouldn't that just
continue to scale up we haven't crossed
the threshold we're like I can predict
what next year will be like I can
predict the next 10 years will be like I
mean obviously I'll be wrong about some
things but like relatively safely
speaking I can predict what things look
like even in 20 years from now but the
idea is that when you cross at
singularity you don't know what the next
year's gonna be that seems like a that
seems like a constant carrot in it where
it's a little bit where it's like well
it's a constant carrot until it happens
and then it happens and there is a bit
of a that's like earthquake though in
California time in the next thousand
years where is like singularity next it
could be anywhere between 2030 and 2050
like if you were to plot out like Ray
Kurzweil he uh has pretty accurately
predicted several of the things that
have happened over the last thirty years
like - a pretty accurate degree and you
could plot that out into the future
that's what I'm saying is there a
difference is it an actual thing or is
it something that may not ever happen
well I would actually but there's
already been like a bunch of
singularities okay right you can't
predict literally the moment the bomb
goes off like I don't know what next
year is gonna be like like the world
could be gone you know it's like that's
a Singler the Internet becomes popular
the singularity like you look at how
people predicted the world would
function before they met became a thing
you know in the late 80s early 90s and
you look at how people predict the world
function late 90s they're very different
pictures of the world so arguably any
one of these like life-changing
world-changing technologies is a
singularity because it disrupts what you
can predict all the companies are big
right now are not companies he wouldn't
have predicted would have been big in
1995 sure also to think about like what
exactly an AI intelligence can be it's
like think about our own brains right I
don't know how many billions of
trillions of neurons we have firing in
our brain but it's a binary system you
can replicate that with software and
hardware right and we're nowhere
remotely close to that right now
but yet the rate of progress you can
plot it out to however many years in the
future we will probably hit that
assuming that we maintain that level of
progress we did pass the point where the
number of connected devices and the
planet are equal to the number of
neurons in human brain oh snap
so like think about it in that way at
that point you now have a computer
program that is a one-to-one direct
clone comparison of the human brain and
how it functions so at that point it's
like okay in theory you can train this
AI and it will think the exact same way
a human can because it has all the same
sort of brain premise I think that we
will get to that point okay sure but so
and then okay I'm yeah uh so is that
soup that's not super intelligence it's
not it's it's this it's the step that
happens about three seconds after that
where it becomes a hundred thousand
times smarter why is that's what I mean
why is it assumed that all of a sudden
that happens three seconds after okay so
here's the cards that where does this
impact where does that philosophy come
from your some facts okay so if you're
able to create a general intelligence
okay hmm basically just some comparisons
the brains neurons max out at about 200
Hertz okay so we're talking about speed
here mm-hmm and this is the important
factor and brains neurons are at about
200 Hertz
today's micro processors can run at 2
gigahertz basically that's 10 million
times faster yeah then the speed of our
brain so if we're able to create a thing
that is an artificial intelligence
basically it can make 10 million
decisions in the time it takes for us to
make one with the same kind of
creativity intuition problem-solving
skills that a human brain would have
obviously it's based on the data sets
that it's built off of and whatever like
what we're talking about when we're
talking about three seconds here is
we're talking about us just like if you
have a decision-making device that's
able to do things that it wants to do so
to speak something that if it's able to
do things that it isn't directed to do
but makes a decision to do it will do
many of them very very very quickly
before we're evil even we won't even be
able to keep track of how faster yeah
and the key idea there is that it be
self improving I get that yes I
understand that but why is there
isn't that happening already no no the
way all these machine learning a I sit
things we have going on it's they're all
directed at specific simple tasks like
Nico was saying and they are not in the
same their tools basically that we are
using we are instead of us holding the
hammer and striking the nail we're
building a hammer that we say head
towards nails it doesn't say we don't
say if we don't we're not building
hammers that say head towards nails and
once you're done with that nail just
look around see if there's anything nail
like heck maybe maybe usually else
become a screwdriver well becomes driver
you know like maybe you know who knows
but make make a whole toolset but isn't
there an inherent like evolution in the
course of all this that well I think the
thing is like right now AI we call it AI
artificial intelligence you get specific
it's not actually artificial
intelligence it's you know deep learning
it's machine learning there's all these
different names yeah it's not actually
intelligence they're just tools they're
literally just tools it's like I can
build an AI that can recognize a
person's face it's literally all I can
do is go face right it's just a tool you
know you just combine enough of those
tools and eventually they become more
than their sum of their parts to a
degree yes it's not just combining them
you need to there's a hardware structure
to this and you know a data structure to
this and a learning approach to this
where you can't just you know say just a
combination but we're getting at is at a
certain point you do get advanced enough
where maybe you can make a general
intelligence that can learn anything
it doesn't just learn how to recognize
faces it learns to do literally anything
but when just rewinding a little bit
here on the topic of AI government what
I'm talking about with AI government I'm
not talking about singularity or general
intelligence I'm talking about looking
at a lot of the massive datasets that
our world is now generating surrounding
issues that we're facing and the
inability of people to comprehend them
and make decisions decisions on them in
a functional way basically right you
know we have lots of easy ones you can
pick out you can talk about climate
change you could talk about abortion you
could talk about education resource
primates you talk about crime rates
we're talking with all these things that
are very
specific directed tasks that we're not
talking about making a dystopian like
slave universe we're talking about
looking at these datasets and being able
to make like just good decisions based
off of them without a lot of the you
know the this humid baggage that comes
with exactly exactly and and so like
imagine me able to look at you're
sitting back oh it predicted that in
five years this neighborhood right here
the cost of housing is gonna double okay
so now we can take some actions now to
prevent that from happening like okay
that that is what a and governments
going to be for the next thirty years
yeah that stuff even just simply that
you know just like there's tools that
people have right now which are just
like all right we're we're gonna try and
predict wildfires here so I want to just
study some like the movement of people
in the area I want to follow some
weather patterns both long-term
short-term the rate of smoking weight of
smoke whatever old all of this stuff to
help accurately detect where the
wildfires will happen next and that way
people then can use that data and
actually do something about it rather
than just sit on it and say hey uh I'm
sounding an alarm right alarms going off
no one's listening okay well let it all
burn that made no sense and I and this
is this is this is functionally really
what I'm talking about when I raise this
topic now talking about like psychic
Overlord with a hood behind a curtain
that you just like type in like your
name and your favorite food and then it
like goes like you will be a Mason for
the route for the rest of your life
I'm not that's not know and that's I
think yeah that's I see that as all net
positives bowled the train to sector for
128 shekels what I'm trying to
understand is like there's there's a lot
of like like Ren you you had mentioned
earlier in the conversation you were
like well it's all just inevitable and
so what what I'm trying to get at is is
is there a realistic analysis that we
can make of like perhaps what these
intelligence tools can do versus all the
sudden passing this unknown tipping
point where all the sudden it is this
dystopian you will be to sector four you
will be amazing in Sector four train
four sectors evening info actual like
when I say stuffs inevitable there are a
lot of assumptions going into that you
know it's like assuming these things
stay true as they are right now so so
they're not so it's not inevitable of
course not okay I just feel it is like
that's I feel like every time I go on
reddit that's like what I see well it's
inevitable giving given that things
continue in the current direction do we
continue to have the economic resources
to contribute you know time and effort
towards things like AI development and
computer manufacturing you know it's
like if for some reason that stopped
then you know obviously it becomes an
impossibility I think it's inevitable if
we're talking about its engaged continue
on the current track they are you know
that's it
sector for meso I'm talking about
understand that's a given the great I
was thinking singularity where the point
was like is you guys do advance we don't
know what will happen here that doesn't
assert before no no I'm saying it
doesn't mean necessarily sector for you
think sector for is an inevitable
possibility navigability sector for is a
possibility of a singularity a
government and the AI tools that we need
to make informed decisions we're not
related to either of the possibility is
unless we implement or in a prime system
yeah there's no such thing every single
symbol in your life everything you've
ever wanted
what if everything you've ever wanted in
life you can just have an ID never saw
work for anything he just could well let
me finish
yeah you can always just like oh you
want to have like a 10-day trip in the
Bahamas for free shirt like like
literally anything you've ever wanted
you can have because an AI figured it
out for you like to make it happen it's
like really awesome you appreciate the
good ones
I know I know I'm just saying this
drives out the Heron at the inherent
human thing again though well we don't
need to get into like well your
definition of paradise isn't actually
paradise like no that's not what I'm
getting into what I'm saying is like as
a human being I truly believe that like
fundamentally what makes you feel
satisfied and happy and and eager to
like take on what life has to bring
towards you is a sense of self-worth
that is established through like taking
on challenges I heartily may I would
acknowledge all of that the second stage
of that is the understanding that it's
not just handing everything on a platter
but understands that people are people
and there's a give-and-take and so it's
not just gonna go like oh my the coolest
book I've never heard of is not gonna
show up on my doorstep tomorrow because
it's analyzed my reading patterns you
know it's gonna understand that that's
really gonna take a lot of the fire out
of like going to a bookstore what the
hell is this I'm really interested and
then you take a looking like I'm gonna
get this this is sweet yeah you know
like there's a certain like even small
trivial challenges quote-unquote like
that lead to a certain satisfaction
because then you go to someone's like
dude look what I found I found this this
is crazy
this party oppresses Bartholomew's best
games you can play in I'm not
necessarily arguing that that's what I
would want either I'm just saying that's
also an inevitable or sorry a possible
outcome of a singularity is that like it
just takes control and it gives what it
thinks everyone wants not necessarily
good thing if I could spin this back
away from these big futurology
discussions is a great example because
you can actually contextualize this
let's say you're like I want to spend
ten days in the Bahamas and I don't want
to plan it I don't want to deal with
this just get me that ticket and this
book
for me the AI doesn't just do that for
you but it probably goes and rearranges
your work schedule for the like the
month or two around it to make sure that
you are still like being a productive
person you're still attending to your
responsibilities okay just helps you
sort it out in a way that like it helps
you allocate your time in an efficient
way so that way so you can you can enjoy
your challenges and you can enjoy your
payoff in a streamlined way that being
said there is the funny version of this
where the AI goes oh wait humans need
this like weird like tugging like pole
pushing changing once what I'm not
tangent there's a push in pole you know
that humans enjoy so I could easily
imagine there's a way that an AI is
eventually just like getting so smart
what's like look there's this really
easy way to manipulate people to feel
like they're being challenged but
they're just basically being vegetables
so we're gonna like basically just go
like look play this really hard video
game for like an hour okay and then you
get to go the Bahamas yeah and then the
game would be actually like a training
algorithm for the AI itself to get even
better
we're completely glossing over the fact
humans are incredibly like influenceable
what's what manipulatable manipulative
so in reality in reality here guys no
more Imaginationland and bahamas trips
at the heart video games to make you
feel so much more because of sorry okay
that's a great analogy but um in reality
what it's going to be it's going to be
mean more efficiency for the government
right
in reality it's going to be your arrest
rates go up your crime rates go up your
you know not crime rates your you know
your handling of crime gets better your
budget allocation gets better the
decisions get more accurate over time
rates goes down over time yeah your
comment goes down and the question
becomes do we want that kind of
efficiency
yeah do we want the government to be
perfect if the tools don't get in the
way of the fundamental human rights
things then I think that it would serve
a good purpose I think I would I would
be sad to lose a little bit of that Wild
West I'm a I'm a mistress mischief maker
I love mischief sometimes the legality
of that mischief is a bit of a greater
you're a real bad boy just like I can
take that risk and and it it's worked
out so I love it sometimes I can just
cover my face and go and firebomb a few
buildings downtown I like to break the
law I mean part of life is skirting the
law sometimes you speed a little bit on
the road sometimes you know it's like so
you trespass on Sanderson out in the
middle of nowhere and yeah it's still
legal for guys like for instance we like
to go on one wheel rides in Griffith
Park after the park is closed out
technically that is not allowed yeah I
don't know if illegals Thomas drones
would fly out of the bunker and come
surround us you'd be checking the GPS on
your phones and Lawrence a ranger and
then an automatic call take there's
street people trespassing yeah I don't
give it the rights to check my GPS which
is toy and then go put you on the train
car to sector four yes it just knows my
habits enough from just the rest of life
I interact with where I can't control
that information like I can control my
phone I can't control my friend's phone
or I can't control you know a camera
that sees my car drive by you don't want
that I don't yeah get in there
I know that we're that's one of those
things were actually at the right where
we need to ask this is this is great
this because this is ending on a
practical note we're at the point where
we need to ask the question of whether
and this is already being asked but
whether companies that are developing
these tools Google Apple Facebook Amazon
whether or not that's now that's no
longer something that should be
considered like part of private
enterprise as if as in like it is
console' a fact the rights of the public
because formerly before the modern
technical era tech the technological age
we had like tools in place within the
laws to sort of prevent things like this
from happening but we're in this weird
gray area where the law hasn't caught up
with the tools that the technology
companies are developing and now they're
having such a massive effect on
individual lives you basically have the
morphine drip of entertainment going
wherever is like what's the threshold
what's the threshold here so like one
wheeling in Griffith Park one that when
the hours it's after hours and you're
not supposed to be there in your
quote-unquote
trespassing now so so you're so very bad
boys okay so we're trying to figure out
the threshold here so let's say we are
dealing with an AI that basically tries
to turn attract crime and figure things
out is the ai's goal to track all crime
is it to track specific types of crime
is it is it because it's not possible
until you have the AI bots that can
actually go out and deal with stuff
until that happens
fringe crime is still gonna be totally
easy to do and get away with and no
one's gonna worry about it because
ultimately human counterparts are going
to have to stop you or confront you okay
but but let's say this AI still is
tracking the movements and those illegal
stuff's going on so how many people now
there's two groups that there's a gravel
gang a one wheelers there oh okay is is
it nonsense we're all friends all right
no no no there's three in others for now
there's people having a picnic
after-hours there's a threshold in which
there's a point of no return here of
love like now we are getting to a point
where the amount of people coming after
hours is basically screwing with the
upkeep of the park because they're not
able to keep up with the fact that all
these people are basically either
breaking in or the things they're
leaving behind or things things that are
basically going against why the rules
were set up in the first place yeah they
don't want to have this happening so you
look at once again big-picture stuff you
do like a climate change thing whether
it's you know like whatever direction
this is heading in there's a threshold
in which you have to actually start
doing something about it because the
rules aren't
yes they're there for a reason yeah
where is it justified to spend your
resources on this because it's costing
you more resources than it will spend
and exactly and that type of Wild West
freedom isn't it yeah
an AI is not gonna look at that and say
you know what those random guys just
having a scoot around
we need to allocate more resources to
stopping them because there that's not
they're not causing an issue and like
the whole point of this AI discussion is
to realize that these a eyes aren't
there for those those fringe issues and
yeah maybe that stuff comes up here
there but it happens in real life too
you bump into a park range and you get
kicked out oh no
fringe fringe issue you know it's an
exception yeah I mean I guess what
you're saying like it's still kind of
boils back to like it's just a tool it's
there to optimize just the kind of the
question becomes can you optimize too
far where you lose the chaos and the
entropy in the Wild West that can lead
to good things we end right if it
optimizes it optimizes LaHaye Oh Park
Ranger just go to the park at 9:00 p.m.
for five minutes because you'll probably
run into them you won't waste any time
just drive by if you see them get them
not try it again exactly like seven days
from now next time on the podcast we
discussed the rights of AI and the
fringe and perhaps we'll get more into
the discussion of what we're leaving off
right here I handcuffs AI handcuffs
artificial intelligence what's really
smart but artificial maybe we should
talk about that next time is we'll see
that's how you make an AI we're really
smart and then you go like we have to
dumb this boy down and you had a few
buttons it's like power level 1 it's
like routing train to sector sector 4
[Laughter]